le début de la troisième guerre mondiale
en tant que seul à penser ça j'aime
enfin j'espère juste qu'on plein de
trucs bon je n'ai jamais quitté même
temps c'est un choix tu fait d'être plus
où je sais pas ce que ça marche plus les
filles veulent coucher avec toi le sujet
très très clairement des extraits de
films québécois pour les ados qui est à
la fiche de paye est ce que vous l'avez
vu stefan jeu les vues et le
questionnement pendant tout le
visionnement est ce que c'est un film
qu'on doit aller voir avec ses parents
si vous avez avec votre adolescent tous
les sujets sont permis une communication
l' extraordinaire
vous pouvez y aller vous pouvez vous
asseoir à côté d'eux ici peut-être plus
de jeunes vous pouvez être installés
ailleurs dans la salle de cinéma où
aller voir autre chose
le titre en dit long sur les sujets
abordés dans ce film là avant qu'on
explose donc ça fait à la fois référence
à une fin du monde imminente et à la
sexualité donc ça se déroule en plein
conflit entre les états unis et la corée
du nord quelque chose qui pas en quoi
c'est donc une fin du monde imminente
une troisième guerre mondiale qui
pourrait être déclenchée et en même
temps il ya pierre-luc à l'adolescent
qui habitait à baie saint paul qui se
dit si on va tous mourir moi je veux
avoir connu une relation sexuelle avant
de mourir je veux savoir c'est quoi
faire l'amour tous mes amis on fait
l'amour à part moi alors je veux savoir
c'est quoi
c'est un film qui plus étonnant que ce
qu'on pourrait penser parce que c'est
pas nécessairement un film qui traite de
la pression de faire l'amour à un
certain âge c'est vraiment un film sur
le fait de devenir adultes quel genre
d'adultes on veut devenir ce qu'on veut
devenir un adulte en est responsable
et notre collègue judith jasmin boudreau
a croisé certains des comédiens lors de
la première du film on a droit à un tout
autre film qui va en plus profond plus
intelligent sur les questionnements
existentiels convient à cette période
d'adolescence
juste important parce que à cette
période-là ya des questionnements je
pense tu nous quittes je pensais
d'utiliser beau jeu c'est qu'elle se
demandait qui nous invite toute notre
vie le film traite de façon vraiment
intelligente sensible je pense que ça
samedi chances de rejoindre le public
adolescent de cette façon lot ce message
qu'on se dira que c'est l'importance des
rencontres
parce qu'au final ce tu m'as termine
avec une super belle entente qui va
faire auquel ici à ton départ
s'intéressant les réactions est ce qu'on
croit aux personnages mais c'est une
autre force du film c'est un trio de
comédiens vraiment sympathique
talentueux il s'appelle etienne gallois
ouvrir les murphy et madani tall
on croit ces personnages là qui ont des
personnalités différentes on comprend
pourquoi ils sont amis on les imagine
comme ça s'est questionné sur toutes
sortes d'affaires dans la région de baie
saint paul
il s'agit du premier long métrage de
rémy saint michel qui fait du court
métrage dans le passé et qu'il a pour ce
film ci review avec le scénariste eric
aboli yann qui on doit le scénario de
père en flic 2 les deux avaient déjà
travaillé ensemble donne pour un
court-métrage s'était retrouvé à la
semaine de la critique du festival de
cannes en 2014 donc site chimique qui
opère et je vous disais que c'est un
film qui est étonnant donc pour les
sujets abordés mais aussi pour ce
mélange assez audacieux de comédie et de
drame
au début on s'installe devant su me lapp
et on se dit ben oui on est dans une
comédie pour adolescents un peu vulgaire
un peu comme american pie
à une certaine époque mais le film
avance et on est plongé dans une
ambiance vraiment angoissant
après tout ben oui la fin du monde
arrive peut-être et donc ça se déroule
non dans ce film là j'avais donc ça
devient un film assez dramatique merci
est assez profond merci donc voilà
pourquoi ça fait encore plus étonnant
quel groupe d'âge maintenant à quel âge
on doit aller voir ce film je voudrais
pas précisément peut-être plus entre 14
et 16 ans ont peut être tiré sa 12 ans
peut-être 18 ans très certainement moi
je leur recommande je pense que vous
adhérez s'en vont vraiment passé un bon
moment à quel âge des grands
questionnements sur la sexualité
ouais il faut être assez gras aussi pour
[Rires]